what's been the biggest challenge in
your property business over the last
couple of years do you know what the
biggest challenge was when I was working
full-time it's very difficult to do to
do a high press job but I almost felt
like I was on cool you know I've been to
America for 3 months Sweden France you
know flying all over the world whil was
trying to build a property business
there's just not enough hours in the day
since I've been in property fulltime you
know it's much more relaxed you know
I've got time to work on the Strategic
side of the business and what I found is
you know where we were doing one deal at
a time and it was taking a year we're
now doing multiple deals at the same
time and pushed him through much much
quicker